you've said plenty of negative stuff
positive stuff negative stuff about
Hassan yeah this is my podcast I get to
get you to force you to say positive
things what do you love oh I'm All About
Love let's go back to grilling me on the
r word stuff where you're gonna make me
compliment Hassan this is gonna be a
harder conversation than that all right
you're there's we're gonna get you to
feel emotions okay uh so he's in the for
people who don't know he's another
popular political streamer I think you
had uh as the kids called it a bridge
burning over Bernie Sanders I don't know
my research is very limited on this
correct but um what do you respect and
love most about Hassan
he puts in a lot of work when he was
like growing his stream from 2 000
Concord viewers to 15 000 he was
streaming like it was like 12 hours a
day like every single day
um so that was that we're gonna get a
lot of work
um he does seem to be pretty good at
networking and like socializing and
making the correct friends and
connections to continue to build his
business what about him as a political
thinker I know you don't think I leave
him on that on that regardless
that's not fair I honestly want to push
back on that because okay I have zero
respect for him as a political thinker
oh there's not going to be almost
anything so I will say I I admire the
fact that through no actual capability
or ability of his own he manages to wind
up at some of the correct answers just
because he's Towing the lines that is
good job for him on that he's got a lot
of correct opinions just he has no idea
why so I think that's undeserved I think
that's too harsh Man Okay the reason I
bring that up is I feel like there is
a deep Grudge in there somehow so you're
the the father now so since you're so
old the grandfather of the uh uh
political debate on stream on live
stream political debater so
there could be some Grudge about that
split that happened or not enough credit
given all that kind of stuff I just I
just think he's somebody that has uh
a left-leaning ideology that's different
than yours he was a Bernie supporter
right and I guess you were not
can you can you explain to me where the
division is he exemplifies everything
that I absolutely hate about which is
which is shallow engagement uh heavily
ideologically driven and you're not
ideologically different absolutely not
absolutely that's that's what we're
talking about like the free thinker in
the real meaning of that word yeah so
the way let me let me qualify you should
place your thinking let me qualify what
I mean when I say that
um I spent a lot of time unfortunate
time delving into the boring world of
philosophy I spent a lot of time
thinking about like what are my ethical
positions how do I feel about myself the
people around me and how that relates to
the world around me and then from all of
these positions I think you might have
used the phrase first principles earlier
um from these kind of like first
principles out of that is where all of
my political positions are built out of
like full stop so if you ask me a
question like how do you feel about like
the right to own a firearm or how do you
feel about social health care like we
can walk through well this is how I feel
about it as like a thing from the
government this is where the government
gets its power this is ethically how
groups of people are supposed to
function this is morally how we relate
to each other and personally this is how
I feel like I'll be able to do every
single political belief back there it's
not like I'm telling you like if I were
to ask Hassan
um what do you feel about this political
topic he's going to tell me what
progressives are supposed to say I don't
know what he thinks about I don't know
don't you think that's a cynical take
why is he just because his views
coincide with the mainstream narrative
mainstream viewpoints of progressive
thing because this I mean why does that
mean he's not thinking
because it's engagement with every
subject is incredibly shallow 100
predictable like I could write like a I
could probably program a script to like
give you every single potential answer
you could have to any single question
you could give again I think that's
pretty cynical take okay it could be the
case that his brain perfectly aligns
with every single man I don't know if
you know it is perfectly aligns because
I think you're just taking a very
selects just like streamers do of each
other a very select slice that
represents the perfect alignment as
opposed to looking at a person
struggling with ideas and thinking
through ideas and then giving them a
pass like a lot of people like I give
you a pass on just the fact that you say
a lot of crazy [ __ ] on stream for drama
like which is I don't say things for
drama it might be dramatic but
I mean you've evolved as a fish evolves
legs you've evolved a mechanism about
which creates controversy sure that you
could say it's not intention but it
happens I think okay sure the extremists
kind of learn that kind of thing and so
I'm sure Hassan does the same kind of
stuff and so like underneath it there's
still thinking being that's that's
contending with political ideas you
don't think so does a really good job of
hiding it there are other political
figures that I really don't like that I
wouldn't say the same thing about so
like I don't know if you have vosh right
in there I'm like okay if that's the
person that watched he also split out of
my community and grew up to something I
know he hates me and he's an anti-fan
community and they all have hey tell me
something you love about what my [ __ ] I
can tell you a lot of things about vosh
I think vosh legitimately thinks through
a lot of his political positions
um I admire or did admire that he has
like his own like position so he would
take someone's contrary to people
further left than him um he's got some
positions that don't fit his ideology
kind of at all like he's his own
independent thinker rhetorically he's
very effective he was willing to sit
down and do research for like his baits
and everything he would spend a lot of
time practicing like his rhetorical
Effectiveness and navigating
conversations he intentionally
purposefully built like a community that
exemplified his values
um yeah I've got a lot I don't we're we
are completely split and hate each other
now but like I have a lot why why first
of all hate is a strong what why the
hate okay I don't hate him but he hates
me because we had a couple of really big
debates what happened well one had to do
with whether or not you should live your
values and can you give me the story
that's a charitable interpretation I
always give charitable interpretation
you don't you don't absolutely do you
don't wait
seven five minutes ago you talking about
Hassan everything I said about sound is
true there is no Steel Man there okay
not charitable
I'm sorry if you can if you can prove me
wrong I would love for you to do it okay
I'm using my gut instinct usually when
somebody feels strongly about another
person in that way it's not coming from
a place of data and reason is coming
from a place of emotion it's coming from
a place of resentment and Grudge and all
that kind of stuff yeah there's deep
there's emotions deep in there so the
gotcha is hiding the the gotcha is is a
surface of an iceberg and there's a deep
ocean underneath that you yourself have
not explored I disagree but I understand
my love is actually a doorway the young
lavasadory for you to explore the depths
get into that ocean and find my fish my
pre-evolved form yeah um I understand
why you think the way you do and you
should you shouldn't believe me and I
understand that because if somebody told
me the same thing I think you probably
just really don't like this person for a
reason or two I understand what you
think that way okay the reality is
though for any political person that I
disagree with like I can give them a
fair Shake it's one of the few things I
think I do exceedingly well on my stream
even with Hassan there's been drama that
he's been involved in and I've like very
when I'm involved in drama he'll always
throw me under the bus but when he's
involved in stuff always like oh like I
think his son was right here or I think
that he meant this
um there was a there was a thing that
came up once we're on well ice cream
fail he was getting roasted because he
referred to somebody he used the
expression [ __ ] skin to refer to
somebody's like the way they looked and
I have only ever heard that in the
context of 4chan people talking about
like Indians or like black people like
it's a racial thing but I could tell the
context and everything that he was
saying he was insulting some guy I think
it was kind of like ncel version
whatever he was going for like acne skin
I think that's what he meant when he
said it and there were a whole bunch of
people that were insulting like oh my
god did he just say racist term and I
was like no I don't think he was racist
I think he was like he was just reaching
for words and that's what came out
um so like that's an example of me being
sure but okay but didn't you criticize
him for something I I was trying to uh
like Googled why the hell you guys split
out because I thought your friends you
should be
I feel like you criticized them over
something
and I'm okay this is very vague memory
but you criticize them over something
and I felt that criticism wasn't
charitable was it Pete Buda Church stuff
yeah yes yes yes yes yeah so I've said
this a million times but there's no
amount of context or no amount of
nuances is ever acceptable people I
don't think Hassan is homophobic but I
think the comments made about Pete booty
judge were really homophone that's what
he said right yeah and there were a lot
of people making a lot of comments that
made me really uncomfortable about Pete
Buddha judge that was insane to me
spurred by the comments of Hassan no but
it was an environment of progressives
all the progressives were attacking Pete
and I felt like his gayness became like
the subject yeah why why throw Hassan
under the bus for that because he was
jumping along with all of those types of
like insults you don't think you've done
the same kind of stuff if I do call me
out and I'll probably I shouldn't this
is that's what the r award was about
that's a good call out yeah no but like
your friend like you should privately
tell them right like hey well no by then
we were sworn enemies so so that wasn't
the reason no no it was over a Kamala
Harris sworn enemies yeah he hates me
what am I supposed I listen for all of
these people I will accept them back
into my life if they ever want to come
back in at any point but usually they're
the ones if they correct themselves
right
no not I'm not expecting anybody here's
so here's the deal with vashina son
these are like the three we're the three
guys online none of us will talk to each
other
um Hassan because you won't give clout
to anybody and vosh because
um he thinks I'm bad faith and then
neither of them will talk to me because
they both hate me you guys should go
like on a camping trip together it's
like Brokeback Mountain but three-way
and just like rejoin refine yeah for
each other honestly just from the
internet perspective for me as a just
stepping into this world
um there's some aspect to which you have
a responsibility I hate that word you
have another word you have an
opportunity I I wish you guys would kind
of be the beacon of like uh forgiveness
and friendship and like camaraderie and
that yeah I agree and even if we
disagree it would be really good content
yeah [ __ ] talk like friends [ __ ] talk
sure versus not like the fact that you
guys don't talk to each other
like I would love for you to [ __ ] talk
publicly with the camaraderie always
there like there's love in the in the
beginning love in the end but you beat
the [ __ ] out of each other in the middle
and that's what live streaming is for
the political discourses that's that's
great political discourse versus I think
what underlies is some jealousy and so
on with this you get this many
I just want to make sure you're clearly
everybody has to your audience yeah I'm
sure you have flaws and I'm just not I
mean in this Dynamic hard to find you
know because I'm your only flaws you're
too modest yeah so what why did you guys
split up because I I would love it
honestly just let me just put that idea
out there for you guys to to make up and
so yeah it's out there of course
Everybody Talks me Vash Anna son it's
crazy that like the three largest like
political debate left-lining people
online like can't do any type of content
or collaboration at all it's so stupid
um what was the reason you guys split up
the the Kamala Harris so Hassan's entry
into kind of like the twitch political
debate world was and I think 2018 I
think he did a debate with Charlie Kirk
and he reached out to me to kind of like
review that debate to like go on to go
over it on stream and he came on we went
over it and then we kind of friendship
developed we hung out of real life I
think when I came to La I think I slept
on his couch we played with his dog we
were like kind of friends
um and as time went on and he was a
little bit more
um he was farther left than he let on so
like I was a Social Democrat he was a
Social Democrat but back in those days
like 2018 when people said they were a
Social Democrat they really met
socialists but they just didn't want to
say it so he was farther left than me
and we had a lot of deep divides in our
approach to politics whereas like I was
very much like a first principles this
is my whole political position and he
was very much kind of like a this is
like the political ideology I'm involved
in and this is kind of like the field
that I kind of like navigate in so there
were a couple instances where these
divides would be laid very bare one was
when I it was either him or The Young
Turks I think it was him
there was a shooting in a neighborhood
where very young black child gets killed
by a white shooter and they did a video
about like hate crimes and how hate
crimes are on the rise between races and
white people are evil and blah blah not
that but like white people with
Community hate crimes against black
people and I remember saying gentleman
was like hey we don't have all the data
yet for this it feels really bad to make
videos about this beforehand because
it's the same type of [ __ ] that happens
at airports you know uh is there a thing
going on was it a brown person are they
Muslim it's Islamic extremism we see
this played out so many times in recent
history probably not a good idea to jump
to conclusions and he's like well no you
don't understand like it's not that big
a deal whatever and obviously as The
Story Goes Tale As Old As Time the data
comes out it was just an errant shot
there was like gang violence shot goes
out of nowhere hits a kid in the car it
wasn't like a hate crime the guy was
trying to kill a kid but yeah we
basically we bump up against a few kind
of political disagreements like this and
an annoying thing is happening in my
community where Hassan is like the
series political figure because he's
from The Young Turks and I'm just kind
of like I do politics but I also game
and anytime I criticize a song people
like Destiny you need to be more
respectful he does this full time if
you're going to bring criticisms you
need to be like really well read and
researched because he's got a you know
more serious whatever which I thought
was ridiculous so by the way if people
don't know he worked at The Young Turks
which is like the largest left-leaning
YouTube channel probably at least at the
time yeah
so finally he did a video on WE skip
ahead to some more minor discoveries he
does a video on Kamala Harris he calls
it kotmilla Harris and it's like seven
or eight horrible things about Kamala
Harris and I'm like okay I know at least
one or two these things are not fully
accurate so I'm going to do all the
research I'm going to have all the
sources we're gonna have a long
conversation about it so that now when I
provide criticism to him it's not going
to be like this horrible like just me
saying something flippantly or whatever
it's going to be like substantial
criticism so I was on a plane ride
um JFK to Orlando whatever flying to
Sweden to visit my wife and on the plane
I review all of the video all the data
do all the research and I read
everything I was like okay I get to my
um my wife's dad's house and I'm at the
table we're having a conversation like
hey we should talk about the Kamala
Harris stuff and he's like okay well
let's do it and we go over it and I'll
leave to the audience to watch the video
enough people say this I feel pretty
confident in this I was pretty
reasonable pretty measured pretty calm
the whole time and I think he started to
get increasingly irritated that I was
levying like more and more serious
criticisms at like the quality of work
that he did
um probably because he felt a little bit
intimidated I think by my willingness to
like dive through political stuff
there'd been a couple of awkward
blow-ups where like on um there's like a
show called the Raj Royale where
sometimes politics would come up and
Hassan would kind of try to explain
something and there was another person
one time on the show that made the joke
it's like instead of Hassan taking 10
minutes to explain this contestant he
just come here and explain it in 30
seconds and he like exploded that he got
so [ __ ] mad at that
um so yeah I think that when I made that
kind of call out or critique of him over
the Kamal Harris stuff he's probably
feeling like increasingly irritated
threatened agitated and then that's kind
of what began the huge split so you
don't think you were a dick at all I
don't think so in that conversation
um especially given that like at that
point because this is still 20 18 or 20
this might be 2019. I'm still known at
that point as being very aggressive
towards conservatives
yeah so and with lefties is what I call
them I think I'm being like very gentle
like my conversational Style with
conservatives you're so dumb like that's
how I'm like doing something with him
I'm like well don't you think that like
this is like a little bit of like an
inconsistent presentation of how like I
feel gonna be honest but I always leave
to the audience they can go and watch
that Kamala video Kamala Harris video
Destiny Osan if they think that I was
being doing that but a lot of people
watching said I was being pretty gentle
so well let me say yeah as a new fan of
this space I hope you guys make up and I
hope you guys fight it out in the space
of discourse and ideas me too and also
with the empathy understanding what the
strength of the other person is what
their buttons are and you know there's
like an unspoken rule that you don't
press the buttons that you sure need to
unless you're doing it mutually and it's
fun because you know you want to piss
each other off so yeah that's kind of
like what friends do you don't cross a
certain line but then other than that
you fight it out